welcome to the weekly pool today we've
got myself two comics torreón we've got
Sal from comic pop
we've got Joel from comic book cast aka
the capes Joel okay a number of CTV
we've got Rob no one cares we've got
Mouse which means Herman and he's rub
it's super effective Rob just frost 400k
everyone thank him fast cross 100k while
he's gone - everyone - wait Rob thank
everyone and everyone's in gratulations
there we go
so Foust and Bravo just hit major
milestones and Joel got a hat I think it
is a lovely hat thank you Death Wish
coffee yes is one of those Charles
Bronson hats it's one of those I'm gonna
be honest 15 movies
tomorrow's all-new Marvel releases we
have I believe eight new comics coming
out tomorrow and we're gonna talk about
them even though none of us have read
them we're then gonna talk about Gotham
and their portrayal of the Joker and
what happened in that so if you if
you're the one person who cares about
spoilers and Gotham please don't watch
that portion and we're also good to talk
about agents of shield and their
portrayal of lash if you haven't watched
it in a week well shame on you
yes alright we continue eagles 4201 has
been subscribed for three months in a
row thank you thank you so much equals
we love you we love everyone we love
everybody equally look we love everyone
equally we just think that some people
are more yes none of you are blind
that is not faust twin brother that is
fast with new hair yeah he doesn't know
what he's have right here and we're
blonde here we're peaking wow when he
does he's the most interesting man alive
skin mouth it's like in a fighting game
this is like the alternate costume
that's DLC we had nine for just a hair
change do see is nuts now man this is
Faust embracing embracing his AZN like
just I'll have an Asian Avenue profile
this time tomorrow an Asian Avenue
profile please tell me you've heard of
Asian haven't you know keep stalling
stretch I've heard of it I don't know
what it is it was okay so before there
was face
become myspace Asian people have Asian
Avenue
it was basically Facebook but only for
Asian people that you can unless you're
an Asian or half asian oh yeah
Asian have da see I'm afraid that would
take me to a really bad place bad is it
still around oh there's a place called
region half calm
where's agent Avenue magazine know this
place was launched in 1997 man that's
AOL level stuff right that's keyword
yeah make sure you guys check us out the
keyword well you would not believe all
like the comic industry people that I've
been you know talking to you to set up
interviews and everything who have AOL
emails who probably created their
accounts i bugged a whole bunch of comic
creators back in the 90s cuz I also at
AOL and like that you know your screen
name was attached to your email mm-hm
and I would just o just blind I am
people like Eric Larson I was like
you're Eric Larson you make dragon it's
like I do
what's up and I'm like alright guys now
that I've actually but I didn't let's go
ahead and talk first up amazing
spider-man number one comes out tomorrow
continuation of the pauper industry
storyline I am hi it's gonna be 599 but
it's gonna be an extra like 60 pages I
know sorry
so I was debating but if it's like every
other spider-man comic it'll be a 20 H
cup of 20 page comic with 40 pages of
additional storylines that don't matter
that's what we're gonna say it's gonna
be if we just variants no it's gonna be
like a zero because you're like it's
gonna be spider-man like it's may be
like spider-man number zero and it's
gonna launch the spider-man title and
then it's gonna have like a ton of other
stuff talking about like spider-gwen yes
silk and all the ones were for cuz we're
getting like you know an all-new
all-different point one like little
sampler and the point one is for like
all the titles like spider-man is for
like these spider-man titles but
interestingly enough nothing else gets
that the Inhumans don't get it the x-men
don't get it mmm there's only spider-man
in the Avengers so it tells it just
sounds where everyone's at pretty much
like it just lays the foundation for
their stories that's right
okay I guess you that it's like I could
not care
about Iron Man spider-man but like I
really dug that first like after you
slugged through the 11 pages of variants
you got like four pages of story and it
was kind of fun it's it's spider-man and
Mockingbird drive on the Spider buggy
and like fighting bad guys in Tokyo it's
a very it was very stupid but like yeah
like it was just kind of like alright
this is like this is just popcorn it's
literal popcorn comic-book fun and slot
had had a lot of fun like playing with a
what would what a woman a rich Peter
Parker do with the spider-man brand and
I'm excited to see where that goes you
turn into a corporation to make money
off of it well you did I mean Doc Ock
did that for him and I'm remains
adequate for it Oh talk doc made an
entire empire I'll just slip into that I
just he got me a daughter in I'm excited
to find out like how he created an
empire out of it because after he took
over cuz he has a doctorate he got his
doctorate in like biomechanics or
something you know something that
someone who builds biomechanical arms
might get a doctorate in progress no
experience that whatsoever the doctor
did something he knows nothing about and
he's running a business which he can't
even balance a checkbook and last time
we saw Parker Industries it had was
destroyed was destroyed it was literally
crumbled and he was like is it Parker
industries us yeah clearly he took the
insurance money went to the dog track
put it all on a ten to one and from that
builder those dog briefly or he found
with money in arson yeah he found money
in arson about earlier how Iron Man is
getting rid of stark tower and I was
like oh man maybe they'll connect that
with part with Parker industries but in
fact as I understand it Parker's buying
the Baxter building which apparently the
only character the only character that's
going to like expose about that is going
to be the Human Torch which is course
like amazing like I can't wait to see
that because you guys KOB Xavier has
been subscribed for six months in a row
here's to you man yeah everybody hello
buddy should spam email Xavier how do
you oh oh it is Caleb Xavier Avengers
number zero so that's that's what your
job where they're gonna set the
groundwork no yeah yeah Avengers number
zero kind of like laser laser ground
working all that kind of stuff I mean I
don't it's weird man see this is this is
you know man what man yeah killing me
you know this is you know this is a
chance from over to start off with a
fresh fresh a fresh start and they're
already doing some inconsistent like if
you're gonna do like that's what a lot
about DC alright DC was like 0 years
zero issues like number ones you know
and Marvel it's just kind of like you
know I mean will do here and there to be
honest though DC has done dumb things
like villains like victorious for doing
stupid things recisions
I found it so dumb I found it so dumb
round Hornet 74s been subscribe for
three months in a row actually brow and
Hornet no it's not oh my god then you
know was Betty just gonna be judging
everything Rob reads from okay well you
guys know like this was the entire
experience in Baltimore like what you're
seeing like what you seen for the last
like men and a half was like Baltimore
over the course of like three days
Sal be lining for every booth than you
and me just gonna hang it back be in
there hey man the two of you were
certainly not interested in going me Sal
Tiffany and Natalie going to go see Mark
Waid and Benny like everybody yeah we
hit the floor let's let's segue to bite
into balls we're really quick just like
we we hit the floor and you know Ben and
Ben and Betty and robber like hey what
do you wanna do I'm like well let's go
to the [ __ ] convention and then we
were there for like half an hour and
like well we could probably go we did it
before you got there yes an entire day
before you got there he was and the fact
is that like the Baltimore Comicon is a
great place to meet creator
get bugs but you could behave you could
cover the floor in half an hour yeah we
can cover the floor and then the only
rule creator I wanted to meet you guys
be lion for I never told me where he was
so I didn't even know Mark Waid was who
you wanted to meet Scott Snyder big time
when I wasn't gonna get in that line
done was just gone to his hotel room
like we did everybody in the chat right
now like don't listen to Vinnie Vinnie
was like oh I don't want to wait in that
line dude me and him and Natalie sat
there with David Fincher and it Finch's
awesome
David Fincher was really cool but we
were standing in line we were waiting to
get an autograph and Bennie looked over
the Scott Snyder line which was like a
hundred people strong it was it was he
was like he's like you know we should go
we should go wait in that line I think
we should Naga way that line he's like
oh come on it won't take that long
if you had agreed with him you would
have been in my defense though as much
as I wanted to go meet Scott said her
again I have met him like every other
kind of been to and I got I got like ten
things signed by him before he was
popular well the light wasn't that long
so I have like all early Batman issue
signed by him
there's CB scene I got everything that's
TV scene because ya see the good thing
is we also got the David Finch at a
really good time too because yeah his
first day like the line was huge it was
nuts trying to get anything signed and
it was basically like Scott Snyder's
line when he first read out but so by
the time we got there everybody got
everything they wanted fund and so we
were like okay cool like let's go funny
because you're neglecting cuz we went to
go see this the situation with Scott
Snyder yeah and then I looked over and
saw David Fincher's line was empty on
like David Finch's dare Rob like let's
go buy a book with his head he's done
recently was the Wonder Woman run yeah
we got so much flack for him and his
wife them so I went over and I grabbed
all the issues and then robbed up all of
the same issues whatever they only had
like a handful of issues plus I like the
covers those covers were no I
with Wonder Woman now I will agree Brian
Azzarello run was a lot cheaper in the
lore and this went more with the Justice
League Unlimited style Wonder Woman
where it's more wrapped into the real
world instead of the Greek gods and
stuff which was okay and I get why
people are upset but I did like the
David Finch in his wife's run so and
there's the fact - I get the feeling
that their hands are being tied
currently on that book words I don't do
anything too radical with long cuz
because we're gonna reveal stuff about
her and Darkseid war that might make all
of this no invoice okay well they
introduce Donna Troy and that's what the
whole plot is right now they're just
dealing with Donna Troy I was like okay
I was like Darkseid war is over and they
were like act 1 and I was like oh my god
Experion play are you serious did you
see the spin-offs they're coming out
with I mean we'll get down Saul the one
shots like for bat God and stuff like
that oh yeah I'm pretty impressed once
taken over the New Gods and the green
engine will be awesome and great and
Batman will be a toolbox Oh it'll be run
by Jeff Johnson I know it'll be awesome
by the way which by the way the identity
of the Joker has been revealed unless
you're in denial so I am like that's
posess Robb never told you this theory
he was working on the theory that I have
because all my other theories have been
right like yeah where did that I miss an
issue because last I heard that man was
like that's his name oh my god and that
was a villain Buddha they said the true
name of the Joker and he said that can't
be true
and then the next issue yes in the in
the most recent issue hounds were in a
Batman take off to look basically they
say like the anti-monitor was created
when was it it was somebody with the
anti-monitor the anti-life equation but
like there's an actual story finally
yeah yeah so basically like like the
Joker was yeah it was it was like there
was a lot like at the end of the comic
there was like laughing laughing
laughing something like that but it was
it was out of left field unless you were
expecting the Joker and so whatever like
there was something basically what he
said is when the ante when the
anti-monitor was made something else
came out with the anti-monitor and he's
saying that that's the Joker well the
book opens with the Joker - is the
theory that the Joker is eternal in
cosplay more from dionysia yeah which
but but then again that proved out to be
wrong though cuz
the Joker was normal and he was
quote-unquote killed you know when
thinking like what I got out of that was
basically like the Joker had used
Dionysian like went became impure like
he got to it after like savage got to it
yeah after a race how cool got to it and
it is just like worn down and that man
was like ah and it was it was weird but
like that see that I never thought I
would actually see that like I thought
they were keeping everything separate
yeah when I was reading that justice
leak I was like is Jeff Jones like
pulling scott Snyder's idea into the
Justice League okay no I didn't read
this because I read so many comics yeah
he was supposed to be yellow spicata
longer yeah can we tell Faust about
meeting Marv Wolfman which by the way
you're so you didn't need to know that
you were sending anything the woods
signed by the writer it's addressed to
you pass and and Teen Titans from like
them like whatever was a Marvel friend
wrote it like initially and it's a
Starfire issue yeah it's a Starfire
issue are you trying to give him a heart
attack
no okay so we get to this we get to this
account like this random comic Stan
because we were like we got to grab
something for fast while we're here so
like we're all going through overall
look at the different things so I was
like well I'm gonna go see if I can find
like an old issue of the Teen Titans and
I asked him because I knew you really
liked Marv Wolfman so I was like okay I
was like Teen Titans Marv Wolfman like
thousands gonna flip his [ __ ] so I was
like do you guys have anything from like
Marv Wolfman Teen Titans run and they
were like yeah over there and I said
okay so I started going through all that
stuff and I was like oh my god
here's a Teen Titans comic that has
started fire I was like Fausto's gonna
flip so I gave it to Sal cuz me and
Benny had to take off I was like can you
please have marvelous line as it was
possible and he was like yeah so
actually Sal wasn't one of the guys
oh that's true yeah so you know he was
very very friendly guy he was a
collecting money for the hero initiative
which is a nice charity for you know
creators who don't have health insurance
and stuff it's really cool cause you
know
so we took a donations that we broke
those and and it's signed directly to
you fastest thank you well I made on top
of that I was going through all the
publishers trying to find information
about like what we can do book wise
like that in IDW at equals IDW now
boom-boom was there and they said oh we
have the woods book but the writer is in
the other side of the place so that's
what I did there yeah yeah apparently
like was the last day last hour and he
was like I'll find who do you want this
out too and I wrote it so he wrote a
special thing to Faust on the thing and
we hooked you he's so touched look at
huh are you gonna come out here and
they're like they're not gonna ship
ticking or friggin Wolfman over there oh
my god do they all show you my picture
though
what do that about giant canvas drawing
oh yeah like it's you
it's the Oh funny dorth leader no no
this is crazy I wanted to get the
teenage mutant turtles one but it was
like a thousand bucks it was crazy
like the price differential between what
between what Rob ordered and what Benny
wanted I was like because we're looking
at this cool huge mirror with tribal
describe but I look at it and I go
that's gotta be like three four hundred
ollars and Rob's like yo man abide we
were we were going into comic pub budget
territory that's how low but with an ax
Rob making it well yeah he was basically
he's whipping out his [ __ ] well
before they even before they even tell
him it's available for sale he's like
yeah I'm gonna take that that's mine
like he's like he was like he was like
mr. moneybags an art dealership yes I'll
take that one in this Rob this really
awesome picture and then they had this
really awesome one about the four
turtles in the original art style and
everything so I grabbed what was yours
and he's like 150 they go over there I'm
like how much is the turtles one cuz if
that's even close I'm gonna grab that
too a little smaller and rousted $50 I'm
getting that right and then the guys
like oh we used a special type of
coloring for this so it's $1,000 but
what yeah was it color in gold
I'm always too awkward when something's
too expensive for me at a convention to
say oh that's too expensive no thanks I
always say oh really I'm just gonna go
to Nate
I'll be back later when Rob and I found
the BBH for sale at the Sprint store oh
dude Benny flipped man I've been trying
to get a bb-8 remote control thing
forever now right so what would videos
was forage it is a Jason story so we go
with it and this bristles look we got a
few year and I'm like I'll take two it
was hilarious um ya know so okay so this
is this big mural the speaker that I got
is Ezio like a blending over the head
the best assassins running over the
heads of stormtroopers like widows with
his knives drawn getting ready to like
attack Darth Vader
in the Emperor's and like in like look
like Darth Vader has his lightsaber out
and as soon as I saw it I was like that
picture is amazing like I need to buy
that painting yeah so like I ran over
there and bought it and it was like
seeing honorable that bullcrap
Conor couldn't do it no Connor Kenway
sucks he does the game if it's about the
game though I spent $5.00 I got a bomb
ination for a star and no one can beat
me play those games because people like
you who pay you just pay money and then
they get a million I care I am
interested to see what role the maestro
plays in this if this is you know like
the next like chapter in that story of
Bruce Banner to borrow a term turning
heel and this is like legal maestro and
this is what he's up to
although it feels weird that that is
like in a video game tie-in and he's
going to be I'm telling you it's a video
game Italian otherwise they wouldn't
have named it test well of course the
video is there to be a video game time
well also like Marvel isn't against
using an old title for like a thirty
year early look to sell something new I
mean they do that all the time
the maestro lament about that yeah I am
NOT against the maestro coming back to
Marvel Universe but having reread future
and perfect for episode of back issues a
couple weeks ago I was reminded how
frustratingly hard to defeat the maestro
is oh and what a total dick he is about
nobody did why we like awesome he's an
awesome he was he's oh no he's he's the
perfect villain he's hurt really because
he's three steps ahead of you
and he's also indestructible and
unbeatable and he's also a total ass
about it like it's it's the phenomenal
villain cuz you love to hate him and it
was hilarious but my question is like
with the wave feature and perfect ended
like how does he come back from that cuz
it's like the way it ended they were
like well he's stuck in his own mind
forever well they brought him back two
other times the first one have learned
not the first one but one of the most
recent ones of course Cecilia's Secret
Wars he's there now and the other one is
after the heroic age Venice did a story
with gentlemen of juniors art where they
go to the future with Avengers you know
the young Avenger team that isn't the
Young Avengers it's like a fake cartoon
movie version of The Avengers and the
maestro's there and he runs that world
and so and then it's like yeah
continuity who cares whatever maestro I
want to write about the maestro I don't
put these stupid young Avenger
characters in this movie yeah you assume
Rob that it's going to be the same
Meister I don't think it is I think it's
going to be the main world maestro or
the main world doc Greene who eventually
grows and becomes mice doing it's like a
real Bruce Banner like bro yeah almost
the life would be pretty cool because we
lose him cuz we've got totally awesome
Hulk now so Choi's gonna become the new
Hawks of Bruce's gotta go somewhere
letting me read Gregg had talked about
that like like what I wouldn't when I
talk to him because he was a comment on
when I spoke directly did you talk to
his eyes did you feel his soul when I
when I when I look into his eyes and saw
I saw his soul and connected with him in
a level that I've never connected with
another human being we we talked about
Bruce Banner and he said that's gonna be
one of the aspects of the new totally
awesome hope is that I guess Benny
couldn't handle but know one of the
things you said is like that's gonna be
a major ass but we're not really a major
but it's gonna be one of these like you
know behind the scenes aspects that will
become prominent later on is why here's
a Bruce Banner the Hulk and where is he
so if you remember at the end he was D
powering all the gamma radiated monsters
he kinda sorta
reconciled with Betty and then but he
also said he was dying is the thing to
because the extremists that gave him the
amazing abilities to be doc green were
also slowly killing him yeah I mean it's
true though like I mean in knowing Greg
Pak I'll be honest like I think they'll
probably be a bunch of like I think well
how will we see like Joe fix-it come
back you know I think we'll see like
different versions of the whole quick to
retell which I mean there would that was
a cool aspect and I felt like that was
just kind of got shuffled to the wayside
you know was like the different versions
of the Hulk but but I like the idea of
having you know all these these inter
conversions but you know at the same
time I do think it's time for a change
you know Bruce Banner has been the hole
for decades and decades and and again he
is hard to write but I feel like with I
know you can get a great job with it oh
he did but the problem is is Bruce bit
you know all-new all-different marvel is
basically Marvel relaunching things for
the newer age for the new way that's
fair and holidays show is young he's hip
he's funny you know he's exciting he's
an Asian character written by an
entirely Asian team which was very sweet
to think about all the characters like
Jane Foster or baba destroy Hulk all
these characters is like DC just kind of
rehash the same stories over and over
and over
Oh same story for new generation
Superman's gonna die get a bunch of
powers good you know it marbles all like
let's just change everything up let's
let's have Foust involved does this kind
of kicker like that's how I explain to
people you know when they ask about
all-new all-different marvel in seeker
wars and I just saw him think about so
it was like a funnel and all they did
was put stuff through and what came out
the other end and all-new all-different
marvel was the stuff they wanted and it
changed me wanted to make that's that's
the easiest way to think about it anyway
Darth Vader number 10 yes I'm psyched
loving them Star Wars books wasn't
really good or so part of the only more
villages could get this in between that
doctors trying all the Star Wars books
are great you should read on the subject
of Star Wars I'm not gonna go far with
it but I would say because Marvel has
Star Wars and because we're doing
all-new all-different whatever we got
cons of Champions in space crap I'm okay
if they want to merge them oh they are
I know that like that's I know that's
blasphemy and like ten years ago me
would have been like outraged but like
today with battle droids and Dooku's and
Darth Maul's and [ __ ] I'm okay with Star
Wars and Marvel Crosson over I don't
want to make them part I don't want like
star-lord to legitimately go find
Alderaan but okay with a crossover
imagine when Star Lord walks into the
cantina borrowing Starling he'd walk in
and be like I just walked in that be
that's a good play sir
this place looks gross I don't know bad
Doctor Strange number one yes cool doc
strange needs a book yes and Aaron he's
getting a movie so he needs a book the
same way every other character who got a
movie and needed a book just like they
need a civil war to around the time a
civil war movie will pass like you're
not claiming that's a part of the Civil
War thing but it's like comes out in
April that's good yeah shut up look at
the timing on what I love about this
Doctor Strange book though is that it's
literally it's literally going through
it saying magic comes at a cost
so we're gonna just torture this
character and that's all it is and I'm
slightly sadistic so I'm looking forward
to it because of that is always about
the cost of his spells - cost of them
anything like anytime like things with
the fan he just goes and sits in the
Arctic for 60 days and yeah that's gonna
costume eventually the hair and his
mustache is gonna start falling out and
you'll have to deal with that now if
Doctor Strange loses his goatee I will
officially stopped reading the character
we're gonna see pretty much the fallout
of him pretty much selling his soul for
that ultimate power at the end there was
never any fallin - that's like he sold
everything and then not the world that
they just drop it and give him a clean
slate because they probably will because
like yeah you know what he gave his life
to save his friends that's enough for me
whatever
well that's what I want to know is how
does this fit in because the last time
we saw Doctor Strange he got obliterated
by doing well I think everyone's gonna
die at the end of Secret Wars everything
and you resurrect I have a feeling
Reed's not coming back about well like I
said my theories yeah like Secret Wars
will end with like dooms setting
everything back to the way it was before
it's close it's literally it's literally
gonna be back as in with the whole
Marvel Universe and they're gonna set it
back and say no more like this group and
that group and that person in that team
and then it all goes back is very
modeled I like Marvel do these events
and they're like oh no wait that would
change everything so yeah okay you know
I J rigged the universe back together
with some duct tape and some spirit gum
and and oh look Myles is over here now
how did that matter
yeah no I like it like he'll do boom
well remembers in the boom survives
that's how old man Logan ever well like
I said I mean yes it makes perfect sense
because when because I don't know if you
guys know this but when I was going
through and I was looking at the
solicitations like Franklin Richards
Valyria Richards Susan storm they were
noticeably absent yeah I don't see the
whole fantastic forums outside of the
cool ones that everyone liked I will say
by the way really quick Caleb Xavier
made it made an amazing point earlier
about rocket and Chewie teaming up now I
want to see that drawing de art take it
away but yeah I totally think that you
know at the very least Reed will be more
like I would like a rumor that like well
we'll see like Reed will be a big reveal
at the end of some stupid event like
Reed Richards will be will return
well here's the funny thing no read the
maker or clearly though oh yeah he's a
major bad guy like and he's a great bad
guy okay we're gonna see that's the
question is there's gonna be the villain
fighting the Avengers in the first arc
by the looks of it
oh that's awesome he's gonna be no I
didn't see anything man decayed that
like he's gonna be on the cover he's on
the cover of one of those books he's
like right on yeah he's like bowling the
Avengers in his hand as I'm a Cammy
principal Iron Man number one is better
than other armors I've seen but it's not
my the only thing that I'm worried about
this is it looks like we're gonna
continue with the secret origin of Tony
Stark because he's gonna go find who his
real parents are we're not real reboot
that was something that I actually hated
was when they came out they said like
he's adopted I was like really
yeah right like who cares that was my
question with that whole thing like what
it meant no one was like oh no the
origins gonna be weird and yeah like if
unless like his dad is Thanos nobody
gives a clap like his dad might as well
have been Steve from down the road who
makes quite good pies he'll be like an
alien like it'll be Korean that's why so
smart or something stupid like that like
that's the only thing I can imagine as
far great idea that's exactly the
apparently he's also broke though cuz
they said they're gonna be dealing with
him selling the towers yeah you know a
place of a lot of men of a bad memories
for the record is also thinking with
this is it the first time that Tony
Stark's been broke in the comics because
I think even Richie losses Empire as
part of the oh yeah he almost lost the
entire Stark Empire because of demon in
a bottle yeah I mean like he's
definitely been brought down to his
roots so to speak and they've made him
you know they've they've they've D
financed him before but yes the one they
said that I was like I don't remember
when that's happened before but there's
no way that that has not happened before
what every hero has lost never know
there's never been an instance where
Tony Stark has been like I have zero
dollars in my bank account I mean they
even tried to play with that during like
the New Avengers arc when he's like I
can't afford to keep Avengers mansion
going it's like a menu but you can
afford to build this
this Trump esque building twice I'm glad
I'm glad you mentioned Trump there South
because that's my theory on who his
dad's gonna be that it was actually
Donald Trump and that leads us into
civil war because Tony thinks and I
could get the Republican nomination
he'll run for president I'd love to see
that that that story arc of stark for
president is an amazing idea
marble okay me I have a skeleton script
already written just payment obtained
you [ __ ] they just had they got it now
they'll just say okay fill this story I
realized something is it just me or does
it feel like we're launching only well
different Marvel a month earlier than
intended we are Oh two months earlier is
it is officially early because there's a
lot of stuff still going here done yes
supposed to be over yeah and it won't be
for another fighter island 505 you know
we've a whole series called Secret Wars
TLDR where we read the tie-in so you
don't have to and like I think I met in
the show cuz [ __ ] I'm gonna keep it
going cuz already started it and I like
I like sticker war so far and that's a
date it's like we might we'll just
incorporate it into our regular reviews
and just stop doing like a tie-in show
cuz like oh well just from our was the
way to go well no can I be honest yeah
for the past few weeks I just haven't
bothered with Secret Wars I'm just off
the event completely because I don't I
am with you I think there's two stories
that I'm finishing off and that is it
I'm done like everything else I
literally I get in from Jason because I
have him order everything for me and it
literally has become a game of Marvel DC
and that's it like and I just throw it
all in the closet yeah well it's funny
you're talking about books that are
coming at Secret Wars number six drops
tomorrow on top of all the new all
because here's the full solicitation we
have an instable Iron Man we have the
Marvel Marvel Universe gardens of
galaxies from the new stuff we have
miracle man we have old man Logan powers
shield complete collection which they're
done they're like marble it's like hey
we're relaunching it's over it's like
man I'm looking at secret number six I'm
looking at star I'm looking at you know
the other stuff like I can't even talk
and all the writers like a lot yeah
and all the writers like Dan slaughter
running around and doing like damage
control on Twitter be like it's okay you
can pick up the new books we promise it
won't spoil the end of Secret Wars yeah
well I'm sure if they're smart it won't
even refer to them at all I'm sure ever
and I'm sure the books will just open
like there was never a secret war to
begin with that's why they're secret I
mean that would be that would be the
smart decision to make but I doubt this
I have no doubt there'll be no reference
to doom there'll be no reference to
route to Richards or a war the only
thing that you'll see is in conscious of
champions like my still be like no doom
thought you could stop me but no or
maybe there'll be a ton of reference I
be like there's a couple more titles
come out tomorrow my list is short here
there's a huge amount of titles is
literally ain't coming out tomorrow
there's a whole bunch told ya no there's
not there's not that many coming that's
one there's only like four oh maybe
there was only six with only oh and by
cold no uncanny x-men or yeah x-men 600
got delayed again so again sorry buddy
yeah see what those of you guys who are
just now getting into comics like
imagine this like now happening except
that it goes on for a year and then we
call it civil war that's all the new
Marvel tomorrow all of those I kind of
want to pick up even Constance a
champion there's like two or three good
titles coming out tomorrow for at least
two or three good titles if you also
have 1602 whichever range later before
we also have like like I was I did
spider Gwyn because I was like well
maybe I'll do spider verse and I got on
Twitter I was like does anybody care
about spider verse and like 99% of
people I've really toned down on the
Marvel because there hasn't been much to
promote for Marvel because they're the
exotic world and everyone's like and
it's funny because they even tweeted out
like hey guys I'm kind of starting
haven't done very much marble light
lately Secret Wars battle world have
kind of scared me directly into only DC
right now yeah and everyone's like we
don't care because almost a year ago we
were we were dealing with with
convergence and being such a cluster F &
Seek we all read a lot of marble and and
Secret Wars being so awesome and now we
got dark side war which is so awesome
and secret Wars which is just so boring
and like what the crap guys like this is
comics it's up and down it's the way
that they're doing dark said war it's
gonna drag out to the former we don't
carry like super no question can I just
say it would it would end now just say
that I love how images taste just taking
advantage of Marvel and DC like we're
just gonna keep putting out stories and
build ourselves up and tada big three
yeah dude like there was there was an
interview that Todd McFarlane did where
he was talking about that and he was
like let me tell you something he was
like you don't have to be like they have
like the number one selling comic to be
the best publisher he was like if your
comic is ranked number 200 and nobody
cares about the other 199 you've got the
best comic book in the country doing a
really big push right now and honestly
because of DC with the DC you like all
rated all this cool stuff and now
they're abandoning it so I feel betrayed
by DC you know and then Marvel doing
what they're doing I've been like valued
by far like so man oh my god okay so my
shipment from from valiant came in dude
like I was reading through some of these
dude valiance killing it and they're
probably it is awesome they're doing
really solid work I'm sure it would be
proud like they're doing the Lord's work
and it's but no okay so here okay here's
a question for the chat do you guys care
about Secret Wars like do you even care
how it ends doesn't even matter to you
if you want to keep reading your comics
they keep telling us we have to care but
the more and more I look at it the more
it seems like it looks like I don't have
to just shove it all battle like I don't
care I don't what doesn't matter
obviously yeah be surprised if most of
the chat if not more and our commenters
after this episode airs are just waiting
for us to tell them what happens yeah
tell me they're like what are you gonna
do pseudo sports and I'm like it's not
even done I do I just wait I might just
be like hey guys like we're gonna finish
think of wars when it ends and like I'm
I just wrap it all up into one video it
was such a better idea don't you like it
back to wait til December for it to all
Angela so so we're gonna be sitting
around Christmas dinner and be like
guys I got the final secret war podcast
let's gather around they fire everyone
Drake no I get ready guys
it's ago I made a video in a Poulos
thinking yeah everyone loves secret was
at the moment oh my god yeah no one
cared no he kept like no one cares about
Secret Wars in terms of use at least
yeah yeah and and what's great is you're
gonna have the end of Secret Wars gonna
be a double sized issue yeah
which features of light which features a
battle between two characters that will
not be present in the all-new
all-different marvel so like this is the
repurchase versus Doc doom 2 cares
you're never gonna see again for the
next five years so it's like do you be
at least Hickman can give them a
send-off though at least he cares about
them it's like look this will be their
last hurrah and I think what helps is
that Secret Wars is also really
competently made at the very like you
know like anyone can just like off
forget it who cares it's sorry it stars
Telos and it's drawn by nine different
people but in this case it's written by
Hickman it's been architect it's been
it's been drawn out and and and plotted
out and planned and rip ik really does a
nice job it's not it just takes him
three months to do one bug you mentioned
Telos tell us is also getting a jokester
has has disposable income to burn on a
telescope as a joke they will finally
answer the questions of I can't believe
that they had the audacity to end that
stupid unnameable event that is
available for 70% off in bargain bin
there was it comic-con there were long
boxes filled with converges in versions
no there were three long boxes make an
offer I'm like no dude that was Betsy
this that's like when it really hit home
because he in Dessau we're walking
around and we found that we found he was
that one coming books that one coming
book stand yeah and it literally was it
was just like like one two and there are
multiple issues it was like multiple
copies but none of them have been sold
means you it skips convergence you could
literally just read everything by
convergence from these three long boxes
for probably
ten bucks you don't mind well like
there's one cause well there's one
positive to that they're clearly not
doing it to make money doing it to
entertain you know my offer would have
been to the guy okay tell you what
how about you turn around for like two
minutes and when you turn back back some
of you go I'll take these comics off
your hands like if you could have a man
cuz I'm gonna make any money anyway
bashing on all of these events cuz
Sigurd Wars convergence and blah blah
blah blah we do have a timetable to keep
so that's all of our books for all-new
Marvel it all agree Secret Wars is just
going blab we don't give a crap anymore
I should just say that until we'll read
the new issue tomorrow and be like this
is Alyssa do and listening Jesus happens
like I'm just gonna probably Jesus
actually happened in he comes he comes
down to Cyclops I am the way and the
white mice okay okay
before we transition off of Marvel that
is that's gonna be one of the big points
of like several of the x-men books is
what happened to Cyclops right he's an
indication the Cyclops didn't dead like
he's gonna be coming back so can we just
talk about the x-men books quickly so
like before Secret Wars started they're
like after Secret Wars don't worry the
x-men are still gonna be around they're
not being it replaced by the Inhumans
they'll still be in the main Marvel
Universe now we're finding out that not
only does the Terrigen mists kill the
x-men they're having to leave the main
Marvel earth to that own safe haven so
they are separated from the rest of the
Marvel Universe you know they gotta go
to planet boxe where they can be safe
over there
fox planet anyway here's the best part
though if you look at all of the x-men
teams they've all been interjected with
other people who are like inhuman or
stew or like obscure x-men that you
don't really know what they are anymore
to try and like basically disseminate
the team's will die from the Terrigen
mists so they'll be like oh this is
serious business we got to get on the
Blackbird and go to asteroid F
you know why they did that right what
because even even if the x-men comics
weren't necessarily selling the best 50%
of something is better than a hundred
percent of nothing
oh that's right sounds were like fans
were like if the if the x-men are off in
their own world and it's just stories
about them and they don't act with
anybody else like I'm not gonna buy it
and so I guess we just got thrown in
with something you know because I mean
even if you only see them interacting
like full-frame for example it's a
perfect this is probably I'm old man
Logan is gonna be traversing around this
new universe and meeting people and like
introducing us stuff you know I mean
they could have just kind of shuffled
them off in his own corner such a shame
too because they passed the books off to
a lot of writers I really like like Jeff
Lemire and Tim Seeley and I would love
to see them you know work on a book that
doesn't feel like an afterthought at
this point you know is it's a problem
they've had since the 90s they're not
relevant they're from a period
segregation or most stuff doesn't make
any sense
people hate the x-men but they love
Captain America that's always been an
issue which came to the forefront and
Avengers vs. x-men and it still hasn't
been resolved like the x-men don't fit
in the rest of the Marvel Universe like
well they had a chance to make a fit
with Civil War but they didn't well it
could have made them people finally
started caring about them but they mean
like the x-men have always been the
reason why I read Marvel with they're my
introduction into marble and they're
late I'm gonna like if you make me
choose x-men or Avengers I'm just gonna
choose X and in every single time but
like I don't know if like remotely the
humans what are they come up they can
[ __ ] off he said the Inhumans suck and
this is all there is to it - that used
to be mutants cool new constant worries
of fast forward ease the fast forward
sign and Scarlet Witch is gonna have
like a series of standalone she's
getting all the comics are standalone
like all every single issue isn't like a
snake like a one-shot basically
I'm sorry stops go ahead like I don't
know for me like for me it made sense
that they were in the Marvel Universe
because I always just read it as yeah
people love Captain America and everyone
because they used to be humans but now
there is a public list of who is a
mutant and they're like oh crap
these people are mutants they've got
how is that they were formed these
powers these people think they're
special they're they think that better
than us I think that's like I think
that's almost a cultural thing because I
go over here in England like it's very
much like if you say oh I'm talented in
this people like oh so what you think
you're better than me
people get so everyone in the Marvel
Universe is a chav or you think you're
better than me everyone is that guy in
the Marvel Universe Oh what pretty much
because you were born with magical
healing bastards you think you're better
than me you're not better it's because
your skin is gold doesn't mean you're
better than me well actually it's like
off a finger and be worth a whole bunch
of money another so basically people
from your neck of the woods are all are
also people from Queens all over to our
next topic okay so that's all new Marvel
we're all excited about it well we'll
probably go over all of it new releases
for the next two months when they all
the new stuff rolls out so we can go
over our theories on it while our first
week is awesome me and Sal and Robb did
I think today which is gonna be up on my
channel I'm not trying to promote it but
we discussed everything that's coming
out and there's definitely some on there
that that was kind of fun we're just
kind of like man don't care so the next
topic is gonna be Gotham so if you are
if you have not caught up in the episode
yet didn't you say off a Twitter you
said off of are all of the news articles
that are discussing it yep I'm gonna
give you two seconds to mute the podcast
for probably 10 minutes because it's not
all we're gonna get one to you this just
might be you and me Benny I think but
you put the whole idea what I want to go
into with this discussion for Gotham is
the portrayal of the Joker he's been
hyping up the rise of the villains that
we're gonna have the Joker blah blah
blah blah
third episodes into Gotham the Joker
died he got stabbed in the neck that's
the end of that but he's not the Joker
he's a guy named Jerome and it looks
like he's been spiring almost like a
joker cult huh because Joker is not a
man Joker is the state of mind don't you
know
like Joker is like Batman like Jo like
yes lure Batman inspired Gotham the
Joker inspire gum that's why it's all
messed up that's what they're playing
off of right now they're going off of
the idea like any idea Joker it's they
said ocher except why are all the Batman
villains twenty years old man here's my
favorite thing about Joker kid Kurt
Jerome he shot up the police station one
episode he held a whole room full of
rich people hostage and I'm like he is a
little boy tackled him right
he's shooting people with this big gun
like that would break your [ __ ] oh
well I think they implied that too
because they showed a whole bunch of
adults laughing and going crazy like
Joker eyes but there's a kid also and I
guarantee you that kids who they're
implying is gonna be the real Joker you
know you know and I bet you I bet you
the next time the shows in a rating
slump and they need something to boost
it hey here's another Joker we didn't
tell you about everybody he's new and
different well it's gonna be interesting
but like overall what I want to get at
with this whole thing is like why does
the Joker need so many origins and
retellings in like the whole thing of
Joker being a god now Joker being
immortal Joker bTW oh it's because
people are dumb and just lets it sit
with we don't know who the Joker is
that's the point of his character
everyone's like like it's real we didn't
know he was when they finally gave him
two oranges like well no I don't care
these people don't learn from that it
doesn't work when you give a character
that was made so you didn't know who
they are an origin then it ruins that
carrot it's because every writer wants
to be that person to be like yeah I know
this character doesn't have an origin
that's the wheel but I'm gonna be the
guy to write and everyone thinks that
they're gonna be the next Frank Miller
or the next Scott Snyder everybody
thinks they're gonna be the ones to
contribute to the zeitgeist to make
everything make sense it because of the
preequalization of our culture
everybody's got to tell a reboot or a
prequel or you know like move like there
are some questions that nobody friggin
asked and nobody needs to know because
that's not how stories work if the story
was told that's all that's all the
interesting stuff it
like when Lucas was making the Star Wars
movies and he's like I'm gonna start
here because this [ __ ] is boring who
cares this is the part where the story
starts guess what he's right Joker like
why do you why do you want to learn
about the Joker being a kid or like
meeting girlfriend and like having
erectile dysfunction like nobody cares
that [ __ ] matters just this dude who was
a loser who fell an acid who's not
unlike Anakin's conquered I think about
it we've heard about me before I put on
the mask nobody cared about you before
that - Bane you're boring and stupid
yeah they you know what main sucks
but like he's a wrestler though with a
code of honor let me say like the best
version of Bane for me was Arkham Asylum
the video game because then the Joker
like defeated him and called him has
Bane because he believes this in this
pocket of 90s we're like no big monster
guys right doomsday here's your bat
doomsday like that's where Bane was came
from Bane is a sack resumed a secret six
is the best version of Bane where they
make him like man I I suck I peeked way
too early in my career yeah it's like
that idea I like that explosion the
character but my point about Joker's
just like Joker exists in this here's
the thing Joker is the most interesting
Batman villain I'm sorry professor Pig
fans but Joker was the most fun
characters I genuinely do like professor
pig he's fun like look the neat like
he's a neat concept cares like the point
being you're gonna you're gonna want to
see a joker fight like and everyone that
you get like you'd be surprised how many
are so lame and it's because really
really good Joker store is a few and far
between and prequel stories about the
Joker are really boring and stupid and
who cares the TV show was doing a great
job of setting up to Rome to be the
Joker and then I thought they were doing
a great job the way he was acting and
everything okay I will say he was one of
the brighter spots on the show cuz he
played it right he liked it yeah he's
like yes I'm hammy yes I'm chewing the
see but we're in a comic that's what
you're supposed to do well yeah he acted
like he would a picture The Joker like
in an alternate universe or the Joker
was in Red Hood and he was like coming a
villain that's how you would have
pictured him and then they killed him
off and I honestly would
liked it better if they just kept going
with that and then ended the season with
him dying why did we go three episodes
didn't like been watching for that's
weird I don't know why would they do
they keep doing cuz they basically gave
him two episodes on a silver platter
where it's like hey kids show your chops
show how good you are and he did and
then they killed him and they did the
same thing with Sarah Ashley was like
okay here's your big moment show
everyone why you're worth it oh and
you're dead
they even said a Barbara Kean to be like
the the Harley Quinn of this universe
yeah she was she hit a dude with a
mallet in the last episode and she's
getting red gloves so yeah I guess she's
the Harley of this [ __ ] it could be that
they had a plan I mean like here's the
problem with TV and especially Fox and
comics and DC and their decisions like
it could be that they had plan and then
DC movies were like no we're putting him
in Suicide Squad you're not allowed to
use Kilgore anymore and also like
particularly I've noticed in TV DC TV
shows which is the reason I don't like
most of them is they're ashamed that
they're making shows based on comics
that's one place I agree with the
flashes banner the flash the celebration
of comics even like I even I'll admit
that but DC in other media or Warner
Brothers really are the ones who are the
apologist they're like I'm sorry we have
to rebrand it a Harry Potter movies I'm
sorry we got it to us we won't call him
Superman okay here he is
I don't have his underwear on the
outside right it's almost like WB is
scared to get on board at the superhero
train but they're like what is Warfel
doing how are they doing this well they
still get it they're like well why do
you like this crap I mean teaches him
what they're doing with dok dok universe
they're not doing it at all they are
doing it del Toro isn't writing or
directing anymore we're getting a new
person in but they're refusing to
release it under WB because it's too
experimental
so all that go to make based movies now
are being moved to New Line Cinema as
protocol exists they're too scared that
if they fail then that's gonna be
forever for me I would like to see them
do that not necessarily like you know
show that they're ashamed of them but
or I want to see them takes a really
cool property and put it someplace where
a bunch of dedicated people who give a
crap are just gonna make something cool
and DC isn't gonna be like Ohio that
character there I want to use them in
that dark in that in that and I Justice
League movie that I'm doing over here
well you can't do this this is this
because I'm doing something well we all
remember lash that embargo right from
the Justice League with that cartoon
couldn't use any Batman related really G
was work it out you had to great cartoon
shows you had Teen Titans and you
Justice League you could never see
Robins show up and you can never a
Batman show up the other one that's
what's really frustrating
the what's the point of having a parent
company that owns everything if you know
the most about that whole thing though
is like [ __ ] if it's in the same
universe fine but they're very clearly
like this is flash this is flash you
know yeah so why can't we have Joker
Joker Joker Batman Batman Batman it's
like they're worried about
oversaturation but some characters in
read America
like the most first-time backer like a
comment the most frustrating thing about
the Teen Titans TV show originally it
was gonna be the Teen Titans cartoon and
then the Batman cartoon yeah they were
they were in the same universe
originally and then the Teen Titans
cartoon got canceled as the Batman was
renewed for season two so then they had
to create another Robin for the Batman
but because they'd already planned it so
Robin was already a thing batgirls
introduced before Robin and it was so
confusing that was really bizarre well
here's here's the kicker with the Joker
and his whole origin thing especially
like when it comes to the TV show Gotham
like the best comparison I could make is
Wolverine like there are more people
that watch Gotham and there are people
that buy comic books yes you know and so
when you really know yes but when they
made x-men origins Wolverine like that
was here is the origin of Wolverine the
problem that Marvel had is they never
had a definitive origin of Wolverine you
never knew was how he grew about that
awful movie ya know there was a comic
about it before that no there was no
there was no they never identified him
as James Howlett and never explicitly
stated as he was and they did
yeah there's a whole book that came out
2000 with his actual origin Wolverine
Origins : really call it written origin
yeah when the Kingdom 2010 yeah ten
years off that or the Wolverine origin
came out in 2000 or 2001 no the movie
will reign origins came out 2009 the one
you're talking about the book Wolverine
the scene in the movie you're referring
to is there's literally a scene where he
like has red robes and he's like no he's
got his claws that's rim straight from
the comic for googling this it's for
guess one and the chat knows it too
music another all they had to do that
because they were doing because that was
a casada Gemma's decision because they
were making x-men movies and they were
worried that the people in the movies
were gonna make the origin for Wolverine
before the comics and so they called
Paul Jenkins they're like Jenkins can
you please do an origin for Wolverine
it's got to be great so that we do it
first and then they did and that's what
Warren came and the basic basically the
origin is that he was a sick child who
was boy boy yeah who is also the bastard
son of the like plantation of the of the
grounds keeper right and and then they
wrapped them in with this character dog
now dog was there was he ever confirmed
to be Sabretooth or - no he's not
Sabretooth okay he got brought to the
Future and he got to like join the
Hellfire Club for a little bit there was
no affinity of origin I mean there's a
whole series especially being Green
origins now you read the original the
original is a six-issue miniseries yeah
well the one I'm looking at came out in
2006 they made it over in origin - and
then they made Wolverine the adverse one
still feels like crazy and they keep
reprinting it
I don't read the second one but yeah I
was gonna say what's the sequel about
origin - more origin I guess it's him in
the woods I don't know was it I can see
where there would be a sequel because in
the original one ended with him he'll
never know his true origin because the
book is burned because the book and he
has no idea that is
and in the wrinkles in his brain yeah so
basically we had a girl that took care
of them I can remember you killed the
girl or if she died some other way he
killed her let's spoil this beautiful
book the one I'm talking about the
Wolverine origin was made by Paul
Jenkins and that came out in 2006 that's
the one you're talking about sooner yeah
Nick's a and yes
cyanide I did do Wolverine Origins on an
episode of back issues was a good
episode you should watch it like that
one yeah those are Christmas the whole
podcast comes feel like a grinding you
can tell we're nerds because we have to
measure our knowledge disagree we all
become that guy no you're wrong that was
that was a definitive that's a
definitive stone actually but no the
point that I was making was this like
there are more people that watch a
Gotham than there are people to read the
comics and if nothing comes out and says
here's the origin story with a joker
people are gonna say well that must be
the origin story they're gonna take
they're gonna take it as gospel which
means that DC would have to effectively
make that the origin in the comic yeah I
mean maybe that's why they killed him so
early on because honestly if you want a
whole season a lot of people gonna drop
off midseason
and if the whole season you think that
this is the Joker and they reveal the
big reveal at the end that he's not too
many he wouldn't be watching okay so the
problem to that Gordon has already in
season two or three episodes and been
able to deal with a Joker level threat
what does any Batman you're 100% right
about that like literally like why
Gordon's already kicking ass this season
just throw a cape on him there you go
like maybe by the time Batman shows up
he's just he's gone through multiple
Joker level events and Batman's like
fresh and off the boat like you could
probably go argue that like Jordans are
so browbeaten by life and other problems
by Gotham by the time Joker
per shows up he's like oh no I just can
we start taking bets on theo galavan he
had a whole speech where's like and my
family was Rick note of Gotham's history
my up so you're part of the court of
owls huh no oh yeah yeah well they've
already said the court of owls is
showing up yeah so it's gotta be he's
like I'm a mystery bill and I could be
anybody I could be totally originally no
you're not you're from the comics that's
what the real somebody will relate to
something this officially marks the
third time that I've been wrong so you
keep a running average against the
average human that's not bad well I've
only ever been round twice before in
your entire life my favorite one of
those times is the Scarlet Witch one the
one where I was like he has been the
Scarlet Witch series and you're like no
she had a series with vision she's never
had her own series I can't let it before
I can't let it because I don't have no
idea what you're talking about
I totally River that we recorded that
episode let me pull it up we're running
low on time here what does everyone
think about the portrayal of the
Inhumans in lash cuz honestly in my
opinion I thought Asians of shield was
great I thought that first episode was
incredible it was great I like how they
made lash look hooky he looks like black
card from the Capcom vs. Marvel game I
mean he he looks like I mean okay given
the budget of agents of shield he looks
like what I would expect don't do that
don't do that like like if that's how
he's gonna look in the show yeah just
mention him like just say there's this
guy that's killing in humans because
he's think Thursday week like or like
we're have like the aftermath and then
save your money like every episode you
say you put you put a few thousand aside
so the season finale lash appears any
letters although honestly like when we
saw lash in the light and then I looked
at him and like looked at a page from
like a recent comic he was in I'm like
yeah that kind of looks like lash I mean
like he looks down on the character he's
bad yeah just yeah I mean they could
have had what
name the guy who stops on stuff and had
him break [ __ ] like it doesn't what out
of all the Inhumans that they would like
they obviously went for it inhuman that
looked different look to you out there
so of all the ones they could have
picked thank God one do yeah
thank God they went with lash and we
didn't get like a giant CG lock jaw it
was also really you're gonna get that in
the movie I gotta save that for the
movie you got to pay ticket money for a
large job and see that's it see that's
that's what I think by bringing lash in
is it's a good move it's an extremely
good move by Marvel in agents of shield
here's the reason why people can say
well it's agents of shield the quality's
kind of low you know whatever they could
pull it off they're like if we had
suddenly just seen a character like lash
in the Inhumans film people would be
like well this is weird
lashes new and from the comics and you
can read about him right right yeah and
they can I and what they're saying is
basically the same thing they're just
like I mean because it's in humanity and
inhuman like it's Charles Souls run of
being humans just playing out in the
show right now and so it's easy to get
on board it's easy to hop in and say
okay and find a copy
I don't okay I don't want HM as a shield
so I'm looking at a picture of this and
it kind of reminds me of um have any of
you ever seen Howl's Moving Castle yes
the scene that how it comes back from
flying around as a bird and he's kind of
half changing into a human and - he
looks like that yeah look like I like
the lash cost and here's the thing that
got me they show his feet and he's
clearly wearing normal people's shoes
when you become a monstrous inhuman you
stop wearing normal people he was
wearing like normal people the most
egregious part of the lash appearance
was actually how horrible the the
playboy kid who plays a dog Lincoln how
horrible Lincoln's powers looked for a
long period of time like when he's
shooting powers or whatever the [ __ ] yes
electricity electricity it looked really
bad like it looked like they asked us to
do it in after-effects
and we were like I guess this is what it
looks like and they're like alright and
I'm like you're holding on this for a
long time like we're either just where
he and days you just shootin powers at
him and I'm like we could cut at any
time guys you could do them
maybe straining to use their powers or
lash reacting therefore no we're just
looking at like this bad CG for a good
like 30 seconds no nevermind to me of it
looked at it looked like the Phantom you
know it remind me of it was like oh man
we got to put lash in the Care Bear
stare everybody shoot your power
we know our powers combined like they're
stretching Daisy's power towards like I
can create earthquakes I can also shoot
earthquakes at you have but okay I will
say this like yes he looks kind of goofy
but if they portray lash and the show
the same like he was in the comics but
you know they were I'm gonna be hyped
that was a coolest thing about lashes he
was literally running up on people and
was just like yes you're a new inhuman
yes you just got your powers like 10
minutes ago but I've deemed you weak and
like he just kills them and Darwinism
okay that's pretty good that's pretty
good that's kind of what I'm wondering
with with it see this is why I kind of
why I'm trying to reconcile this with
like the upcoming Inhumans film because
here's my question what is happening
right now
in the ages of shield happened long
after the inhuman royal family was
established like yes is literally like
Black Bolt blew up the unity urgent bomb
Inhumans you cropping up everywhere the
inhuman royal families in disarray a
tillens fallen there's really no like
all that showed up because it was it
doesn't that's what I'm saying like in
the comics that's when all that happened
my question is the movie how's that
gonna fit in now my takes place further
in the past or it's all black bastards
like you what I said like absolutely I
think is going to be a prequel it's
gonna be like here's here's the Inhumans
leading up to what's going on right now
innate a socio and all that kind of
stuff and as it spills over because it
will you know as it spills over into the
poison a matter you know what would be
interesting is if between now and when
Dean humans movies
starts filming if they get the rights to
the Fantastic Four back all they have
the fellow Beach and a back in the
background of this Inhumans movie that's
whether that's where that team works in
the background like beautiful poetic
irony the Fantastic Four take a
background seat to the what we launched
you guys yeah I was just once I always
imagined this like I want to like just
totally off topic I want to see like a
skit or something where like you have
Ben Grimm the thing on like celebrity
jeopardy or something like that on its
own oh yes and like he asked him a
question you can't answer and he's just
like uh also be there actually
somebody's brought in something so we
got two more topics to roll through so
five minutes on thoughts on heroes are
born
oh yes everything that I it would be oh
my god I wonder I'm watching Muppets
Castle
yeah Muppet okay okay Benny was it just
me or were you like were you just like
like that classic heroes oh my god
moment when Zachary Levi was revealed to
have been like what's-his-name from the
first season the exploding man the guy
that like they could turn on cuz you
remember that from the first season
right yeah the guy that could set off
like nuclear bombs like that's that's
Zachary Levi you know and like he's a
guy that has like all this energy that
basically like combust and stuff my
thought is he's the one that blew up
what Yuma call it and didn't yeah I
think he's the one that blew up Odessa
and didn't realize it was him Rudy that
was mine was wiped or something like
that I really hope we don't go all 13
episodes and find out at the age when I
quit heroes halfway through season three
and was amazed when I looked on Netflix
that went on for as long as it did yeah
it was feeling very bad
watch season one ensue and then just go
to season five just yeah don't expect to
see a majority of those people anyway
I'm glad that they're not they're not
bringing those guys back look I've loved
Matt Parkman probably one of my favorite
characters his power was awesome and his
dad was like the best display of what
his powers could become but I'm glad
they're not bringing them back as like
mainstay characters like I like seeing
fresh faces you know and I think that
was a really good call having said that
it's also a very smart decision to make
this a miniseries because I could see
how this could go disastrously wrong oh
they wanted to turn it into the lost
model like we don't ever really need to
fully explain things just good that
worked out great for loss didn't it
let's not discuss lost again
no but they have the whole rider strike
and everything know the like heroes
reborn is turning out pretty solid I
think it's gonna be pretty cool so I'm
really interested to see how it happens
I mean obviously like the whole you know
eclipse is gonna play a much bigger role
but I'm curious to see all that comes
together so okay in the other one that
and I don't I have no information on
this I just heard it happened but it's
been too long
like I didn't check it the new Justice
League cartoon got announced it's gonna
be called a JLA justly animate some
people are terrified though cuz the hot
new rumor around animation circles is
that it's going to have the same
animation style as that new scooby-doo
show yeah yeah what does that look like
cuz like I can't it looks like the first
season of Family Guy we talked about
this on the first episode of the
scooby-doo show where John Cena turns up
okay no that's actually that that's
better that's the brain in Viet II
movies no I'm talking about the new
scooby-doo show that's about to start
should we do oh my god if you look up
scooby-doo 2015 what the heck is that
but looks like early family guy doesn't
it yeah does it look as bad as any
Marvel cartoon oh it looks a little
worse yes I mean like oh dude you guys
are so full of crap do those movies look
amazing why no why do you like the
Doctor Strange really looks awesome
no he's talking like the new Marvel
stuff like ultimate spider-man and like
Avengers Assemble
the galaxy looks good I like the
animation gardens the galaxy that's a
little better it's step up they actually
look like they gave a crap a little bit
I know they look like the Guardians yeah
I just want to know why Belma looks like
Meg from Family Guy because they say
maybe this damn arts does she's gross
she wears sweaters and has glasses yeah
this bunny got a hotter and hotter
maybe the cultures hotness index for
Velma need to be rebooted they were like
no now she's just thin and has like
crazy well she's a hipster like in one
of the live-action movies they did with
like them in high school she was played
by like a hot asian chick and I'm like
whoa yeah if you want that set you got
to go listen to comic book cast is we
have no shame and we'll do that sort of
stuff
endlessly hey one thing I wanted to talk
about before we call it before we call
it a night it's Civil War - electric
Boogaloo what was that type - like I'm
not with - I posted on Twitter and I was
like Civil War - like I thought that's
think what a civil war was and I posted
every of you every night and as I
mentioned politically it makes a lot of
sense right now we're in an election
year there's a lot of stuff going on
maybe they want to tap into that same
kind of like Civil War was lightning in
a bottle
all right they're not gonna be able to
duplicate that before we had a lot of
events of superheroes fighting now
that's a common place yeah okay just I
just want to read this for the chat this
is the title I came up with for this
event Civil War - electric boogaloo the
movie the graphic novel video track TV
movie game comic gonna be doing Civil
War - the quest for residuals no it's
gonna be like the Civil War - is gonna
be a retcon of the original Civil War
who's gonna be all the all Civil War -
is gonna be just like how they attempted
to make
rage of Ultron right on top of me maybe
it's not you know who just kind of
depends on how see course plays out but
apparently now officially rage of Ultron
is in continuity yeah really
if you read the new ant-man they're just
like yep that's a new D that happened
they're like oh he died yeah by the way
he lost everything do you Scott I like
how they do that I like how they're like
don't like here's a story you know and
then just like in the back panel of a
last page of a comic that sell that sold
like 15,000 issues they're like in
continuity it's to encourage us to get
Marvel unlimited desire in six months
time we'll be able to figure stuff out
for ourselves
yeah I understand like maybe I guess
maybe it has to do with the whole
distributor thing but why would you
launch model unlimited and then say like
here's a really great program like a
website that lets you read all the
comics you want to read for 10 bucks a
month except the stuff that you want to
model first showed up in my
1960-something do you want to read about
when he died in 1982 like especially now
with their new reboot but do you want to
read it I mean let's face it for us it's
like a blessing no I've got Marvel
unlimited I got I got like comiXology I
buy stuff all the time I could but we
need it for work we wouldn't be able to
do it without a head yesall making
youtube videos about how many books I
wouldn't have Marvel unlimited oh no all
right guys and all that we're gonna end
the show because we've hit are a lot of
time limit of the day I think she said
all of our topics actually I think it's
the first time we've ever actually gone
through all of the topics oh yeah go
don't worry guys we will be here next
week we took a couple weeks off because
there was nothing really going on but
now all the shows who started the comics
are coming out again being a Sal they're
gonna be a New York Comic Con this
weekend rob is being a little [ __ ]
about it [ __ ] about it
fastest pitch it out to you so it's me
as out I'm filming a thing that I can't
talk about say man I need a pass and
eris over at variant comics are gonna be
doing the valiant foods on Saturday at
11 a.m. we may try to do a meet-up for
people who don't have tickets because I
know New York Comic Cons sold out salad
print which can have to find us a store
because I tried Midtown lace that
they're busy yeah so but yeah we're
gonna be in New York this weekend guys
if you want to meet up we'll be around
otherwise thank you so much for watching
us today we will be here next week once
we get back we're gonna be chat we're
actually gonna start doing everything
properly which includes
more shows on this channel we're gonna
start doing the the websites getting a
complete revamp and a few other things
are going on but we are not going
anywhere trust us once again
congratulations to rob for 400k and
congratulations to faust for 100k I
don't know if we congratulate you last
time fast I know it's been like three
weeks since you've been here so so
congratulations to Joel for 1000 subs on
Cape Joel it was 1,000 before it's like
500 something but yeah whatever and and
also while I'm at it congratulations to
come upon for their twenty thousand
because I know we didn't actually down
set on here don't worry about thank you
thank you so and all that no guys we
will see you later there is not gonna be
an after show today because stop yeah
I'm still recovering like all the power
went off in Kentucky rob is now in the
dark is running on jelly my computer's
still running somehow it's magic
alright guys thank you so much we will
see you soon
right here at the weekly bull please